[Music]
foreign
[Music]
review the show where we break down a
year to bring you some of the most
notable moments in TV and film month by
month the year was 2010. Netflix was
swimming Upstream Catherine Bigelow made
Oscar history Facebook hit 500 million
users and Steve Jobs released the first
ever iPad the hits keep coming with the
launch of Instagram and subsequent rise
of zany Styles in One Direction so what
was it about this year that kept us up
all night making Midnight Memories
watching the stories of Our Lives never
wanting to take me home tell me 2010
What Makes You Beautiful well let's take
a trip down memory lane to find out
here's your year in review 2010 Edition
[Music]
crazy people they're the perfect
subjects they talk nobody listens
instead of dark out
he saw what human beings are capable of
doing to each other right
but Christ sakes we we fought a god War
to stop them and now now I find out it
may be happening here on our soil based
on Dennis lahon's novel of the same name
Shutter Island is a psychological
Thriller by Martin Scorsese and starring
Leonardo DiCaprio Mark Ruffalo Michelle
Williams and Ben Kingsley Leo's
character Teddy Daniels is a U.S Marshal
investigating an asylum that sits Atop A
desolate dreary storm-inflicted Island
in Boston Harbor ah Paradise
which would be worse
to live is a monster
I want to die is a good man
Teddy's tormented past impedes his work
and finds him at odds with his own
sanity and itching to know what's going
on in that darn Lighthouse despite mixed
reviews the film opened at number one in
the U.S box office and scored Scorsese
to save that five times fast scores
his second highest grossing film to date
critics say it may not rank with
scorsese's best work but shutter
Island's gleefully Unapologetic genre
Thrills represent the director at his
most unrestrained
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
we know Alice has returned to underland
do you know where she is
I've been considering things that begin
with the letter m
Tim Burton's Alice in Wonderland Stars
Mia vasakowska Johnny Depp and Helena
Bonham Carter the Disney distributed
film takes some narrative Liberties
while also respecting the iconic
elements of Lewis Carroll's novels like
trippy dreams Whimsical Mad Hatters and
Jabberwockies it's like a dragon just
weirder like most Burton Productions it
was lauded for its imaginative visual
landscape utilizing the latest CGI
technology and visual effects designed
by Sony's imageworks walk with his head
can't watch
[Music]
Alice in Wonderland was the sixth film
in history to gross over one billion
dollars worldwide don't believe me go
ask Alice critics say Tim Burton's Alice
sacrifices the book's minimal narrative
coherence and much of its heart but it's
an undeniable visual treat okay there
bud we're gonna take this nice and slow
here we go well here we go position
three no four
[Music]
oh and speaking of Jabberwockies How to
Train Your Dragon is a computer animated
fantasy film inspired by Christina
Cowell's 2003 novel of the same name the
film was produced by Dreamworks and
features a first-rate voice cast a
poignant script and an arresting score
by John Powell it tells the story of
Hiccup a teenager who builds an unlikely
friendship with the injured Dragon heat
coins toothless
[Music]
happy to see you too buddy
oh
their relationship conflicts with the
fighting traditions of the Vikings but
presents an opportunity for positive
change in a culture Bound by its past
with two sequels two Oscar nods a
worldwide gross of 500 million dollars
and a certified fresh score at 99 on the
Tomato Meter How to Train Your Dragon
soars Above the Rest critics say
boasting dazzling animation a script
with surprising dramatic depth and
thrilling 3D sequences How to Train Your
Dragon sores
I don't want to join your super secret
boy band no no no it's yeah I remember
you do everything yourself how's it
working out for you it's
I'm sorry I don't want to get up from
the wrong foot door look at the patch of
the eye RDJ returns for the second
installment in the Iron Man film
franchise directed by John Favreau and
written by the multi-faceted Justin
Thoreau the film was the second Marvel
movie to be set within the Avengers
Universe we follow mad genius
billionaire Tony Stark as he thwarts the
military's interest in his technology
struggles with his declining health and
scuffles with a vindictive Russian
scientist
speaking of Thieves where did you get
this design
my father
I'm Tom uncle
I never heard of him
my father is the reason you're alive is
it better to have critical or commercial
success I say it's not too much to ask
for both Iron Man 2 grossed over 302
million dollars in the U.S and received
an Oscar nomination for best visual
effects critics say it isn't quite the
breadth of fresh air that Iron Man was
but this sequel comes close with solid
performances and an action-packed plot
wow are we clear yeah
says we're good you better pray we are
Ricky boy because I'm gonna spin her
around
13.5 million Americans tuned in for the
end the series finale of everyone's
favorite trapped on an island drama
apart from Naked and Afraid directed by
Jack Bender written by Damon Lindelof
and Carlton cues the episode was
polarizing and became one of the most
controversial season finales of all time
The Huffington Post selected the end as
their choice for the most disappointing
series finale of all time and the Daily
Mirror said that it left viewers with
even more unanswered questions we gotta
go now understand
Lock's dead
why is this still happening because
whatever Desmond turned off
[Music]
I need to turn it back on again
it doesn't work if I don't get it done
you all need to leave now you need to be
on the plane
debuting on ABC in September 2004 the
series spawned six seasons 121 episodes
and won 11 Emmys the overall success and
Adoration of lost will far outweigh that
irksome finale I think I don't know
though people are still pretty upset
critics say lost shift in central
mythology won't satisfy all viewers but
persistent fans will find Solace and the
show's strong performances and continue
dedication to its themes
foreign
in one night stringent uh tough
inflexible it's not like you're gonna
actually use them
marriage wishes I mean it's not like you
go to college and then you start
speaking a completely different language
it's about getting into college
meritocious um phony flashy
citing Alfred Hitchcock as an influence
Marlene King's Pretty Little Liars is a
twisted teen drama that originally aired
on the freeform Network the series is
Loosely based on Sarah's Shepherd's
novel of the same name and follows the
lives of five best friends shaken up by
a sudden disappearance and the Mysteries
that ensue it was one of the first shows
to exploit the growing popularity of
social media utilizing Twitter
discussion forums and Facebook live to
connect with audiences critics say
murder mystery and makeup these troubled
but well-dressed teenagers take us on a
compelling guilty pleasure cruise
through the first season of Pretty
Little Liars
look I can see daylight we're gonna be
okay
I don't think that's daylight
Woody and Buzz return yet again in
Pixar's Toy Story 3. the ensemble cast
features veterans Tom Hanks and Tim
Allen and new additions Michael Keaton
Whoopi Goldberg and Timothy Dalton as
Andy prepares to leave for college his
toy troop is mistakenly donated to a
daycare center where the kids aren't so
nice to our little plastic friends led
by Woody the gang Must Escape and find
their way home wherever that may be
[Music]
and Beyond
now you got a promise to take good care
of these guys
they
mean a lot to me
the film was 2010's biggest box office
hit earning over 1 billion dollars
worldwide which also made it the highest
grossing animated film to date in
addition to Commercial Success Toy Story
3 was nominated for five Oscars and has
a certified fresh score of 98 on the
Tomato Meter to infinity and beyond
Pixar critics say definitely blending
comedy adventure and honest emotion Toy
Story 3 is a rare second sequel that
really works
doesn't he own a shirt
eclipse is the third movie based on
Stephanie Meyer's wildly popular
Twilight book series directed by David
Slade the film finds Bella Kristen
Stewart battling an angry vampire a
different Angry vampire and having to
choose between her love for Edward
Robert Pattinson and her friendship for
Jacob Taylor Lautner of course this begs
the age-old question that's puzzled
philosophers and Scholars since the
breaking dawn of time Team Edward or
Team Jacob forget it
she may need her toes someday
let's face it
I am hotter than you Eclipse was a box
office win but received mixed reviews
such as this one from Roger Ebert that
claims the mountain range in the film
looks like Landscapes painted by that
guy on TV who shows you how to paint
stuff like that don't you dare bring Bob
Ross into this critics say stuffed with
characters and overly Reliance on
uninspired dialogue Eclipse won't win
the Twilight Saga many new converts
despite an improved blend on romance and
action fantasy
[Music]
foreign
no I am not
a little but we have had a pretty good
year ourselves and you guys are all
right in my book no no races you're not
going to get any noises ah the film that
introduced us to those adorable little
minions and the film that launched the
highest grossing animated franchise in
history take that Pixar Despicable Me is
the story of a super villain named Gru
voiced by Steve Carell who devises an
evil plan to hijack the moon nothing
will stand in his way except of course
the three precious orphan girls who are
fixated on making him their dad as I was
saying Hey Oh somebody broke that okay
okay clearly we need to set some rules
rule number one
you will not touch anything uh-huh
when I touched the floor the film was
produced by illumination and has been
followed by two sequels two spin-off
prequels several short films a TV
special video games and a theme park
attraction critics say borrowing heavily
and intelligently from Pixar and Looney
Tunes Despicable Me is a surprisingly
thoughtful family-friendly treat with a
few surprises of its own let me ask you
a question you you never really remember
the beginning of a dream do you you
always wind up right in the middle of
what's going on I guess yeah so how did
we end up here next up we bring you
Christopher Nolan's Inception the Sci-Fi
action thriller that features dreams
inside dreams infiltrating other dreams
all stuffed within a Dream It's
introduction of movies
foreign
with an ingenious script also by Nolan
and an extraordinary cast that includes
Leonardo DiCaprio Ken Watanabe Joseph
Gordon-Levitt Elliot page Tom Hardy
Cillian Murphy Tom berringer and Michael
Kane Inception checks all the Box Office
boxes the film earned
836.8 million dollars worldwide won four
out of eight Oscar nominations including
best cinematography and best visual
effects and is certified fresh with a
Tomato Meter score of 87
somebody pinched me
[Music]
so you want guards are gone and when I'm
dead what it takes is little army only
an idiot would do this job how much oh
like I said
I'm busy anyway so give this job to my
friend here he loves playing in the
jungle right right bust
three-part film series The Expendables
features a shredded Ensemble of
Hollywood tough guys Stallone Jet Li
Jason Statham Dolph Lundgren Steve
Austin Terry Crews and Mickey Rourke
Sloan directs and stars as Barney Ross a
mercenary who leads his company of loyal
men to the fake South American country
of belena which quickly regresses into a
suicide mission
great job
that was a statement
sure it's over the top the plot gets
Rocky at points and it may even leave
some Cliffhangers but the Expendables
Judo chopped the box office opening at
number one and grossing 274 million
dollars critics say it makes good on the
old-fashioned action it promises but
given all the talent on display The
Expendables should hit harder
what did you think these were
kisses seven little kisses seven deadly
exes
shot of the Dead director Edgar Wright
delivers yet another cult classic hit
with Scott Pilgrim Vs the World based on
the graphic novel by Brian Lee O'Malley
Michael Sarah plays Scott a bass
slapping stud who unexpectedly falls for
the chameleon-haired Ramona Flowers all
would be groovy if not for her Army of
ex-boyfriends who all share the same
goal eliminate Scott Pilgrim I totally
understand if you don't want to hang out
anymore no no I I want to hang it's
you know the whole evil ex-boyfriend
thing is it's no biggie unfortunately
the film bombed and failed to recoup its
Hefty budget of 80 million dollars but
that didn't stop audiences and critics
from loving its eye-popping visuals and
Innovative use of video game tropes and
imagery critics say its script may not
be as dazzling as its eye-popping
visuals but Scott Pilgrim vs The World
Is Fast funny and inventive
[Music]
what you didn't have
no no of course not you liar you totally
lost your v-car damn no I didn't yes you
did tell me everything really I'm not
that kind of girl taking inspiration
from Nathaniel Hawthorne's The Scarlet
Letter easy a is a Cali based team
comedy directed by Will Gluck Emma Stone
Sparkles as all of a clean-cut high
school student entangled in her own Web
of Lies the role with slingshot Stone's
career and secure her as a global star
with box office draw the film prospered
financially earning 75 million dollars
on a humble budget of 8 million critics
say it owes a huge debt to older and
better teen comedies but easy a proves a
smart witty showcase for its
irresistibly Charming star Emma Stone is
it true what they're saying I believe so
my Lord I'm afraid we'll know some
people on it I don't suppose there are
any lists of survivors yet I understand
most of the ladies were taken off in
time
you mean the ladies in first class
God help the poor Devils below decks
on their way to a better life
what a tragedy created by Julian fellows
Downton Abbey became the most watched
series on both PBS and ITV following the
opulent lives of the Crawley family the
show begins with the male heirs to the
fictional estate Downton Abbey dying on
the Titanic leaving confusion as to
which Offspring will take over once the
current Lord dies toss in some
post-edwardian era events such as the
first world war the Spanish influenza
pandemic and the Marconi Scandal and
you've got some ACE entertainment
Downton Abbey earned the most Emmy
nominations of an international
television series in history 27 to be
exact winning 15. the shaw also ran for
six seasons and was adapted into a 2019
feature film critics say Downton Abbey
transcends its soapy plotting with witty
dialogue lavish costumes and sets and an
outstanding cast
foreign
you have the minimum amount
the rest of my attention is back at the
offices of Facebook where my colleagues
and I are doing things that no one in
this room including and especially your
clients are intellectually or creatively
capable of doing
did I adequately answer your
condescending question the social
network is the story of Mark Zuckerberg
the Harvard computer whiz who built
Facebook you know the largest most
consequential social network in history
the plot is aptly summarized in its
tagline you don't get to 500 million
friends without making a few enemies
with graceful Direction by David Fincher
a superior script by Aaron Sorkin and a
striking score by Trent resner and
Atticus Ross The Social Network was
tagged for Glory they don't want you
they want your idea and they want you to
say thank you while you
excuse me wipe your chin and walk away
the film was critically acclaimed
garnering eight Oscar nominations and
winning for best adapted screenplay best
original score and best film editing but
how many likes did it get that's the
real question critics say impeccably
scripted beautifully directed and filled
with fine performances the social
network is a riveting ambitious example
of modern filmmaking at its finest
little girl
I'm a policeman
little girl
Don't Be Afraid okay
little girl
arguably the biggest show of the decade
AMC's The Walking Dead is a
post-apocalyptic drama infused with
zombies AKA Walkers so many Walkers the
show Stars Andrew Lincoln in the lead
role of Rick Grimes a Sheriff Deputy who
wakes from a coma to discover a world
where humans in survival mode proved to
be more threatening than the rampant
zombies themselves
laughs
based on the comic book series of the
same name The Walking Dead has become a
mega franchise with a spin-off series a
web series films novels video games the
list walks on critics say blood
splattered emotionally resonant and
White Knuckle intense The Walking Dead
puts an intelligent spin on the
overcrowded zombie sub genre
foreign how can I help you Mr Potter
well
sleep
it was about something you were wearing
around your neck at the wedding it was a
symbol
you mean this
yes
that exactly
what we wondered is
what is it David Yates directs this
two-part fantasy feature in the Harry
Potter film franchise based on JK
Rowling's not you know what you already
know what Harry Potter is moving on our
usual slightly matured Heroes return as
we follow Harry Ron and Hermione on
their mission to destroy the horcruxes
the source of Voldemort's immortality
now I'll have to speak to it in order
for it to open when it does don't
hesitate
I don't know what's in there but it'll
pull up a fight a bit of Riddle That was
in that diary tried to kill me
Deathly Hallows part one was the third
highest grossing film of 2010 and
received Oscar nods for best art
Direction and best visual effects
critics say it can't help but feel like
the Prelude it is but Deathly Hallows
part 1 is a beautifully filmed
emotionally satisfying penultimate
installment for the Harry Potter series
my husband is um
but is required to speak public
should change jobs
we can't
indention servitude
nothing of that nature yes British
Australian director Tom Hooper delivers
this historical drama about a young
prince soon to take the throne as King
George IV only problem is this Prince
suffers from a speech impediment and
must overcome his stammer if he hopes to
effectively lead the United Kingdom
Colin Firth Helena Bonham Carter and
Jeffrey Rush give elevated performances
that garnered widespread Acclaim the
film was also nominated for 12 Oscars
the most of any film that year winning
for Best Picture Best Director best
actor Firth and best original screenplay
listen to me listen to you by what right
my divine right if you must I'm your
king no you're not you told me so
yourself you said you didn't want it why
should I waste my time listening because
I have a right to be and I have a voice
aside from critical success a King's
Speech was a commercial Victory grossing
427.4 million dollars internationally
against a budget of 15 million dollars
dare I say a film Fit For A King two on
the nose critics say Colin Firth gives a
masterful performance in The King's
Speech a predictable but stylishly
produced and rousing period drama
[Music]
big day's getting closer and closer huh
well I can't wait I think you're gonna
be amazing
thanks known for his surrealist and
often disturbing style director Darren
Aronofsky doesn't disappoint with Black
Swan a psychological horror movie that
granted Natalie Portman her first Oscar
Portman plays Nina the tenacious
ballerina whose dark side is exacerbated
by a flashy newcomer named Lily the plot
centers around a production of the
ballet Swan Lake in which Lily and Nina
must contend for the principal role
he made her my ultimate
wow there's always an alternate Lily's
the best choice no but she wants my role
every dancer in the world wants to roll
no it's different she's after me she's
trying to replace me nobody's after you
no please
Black Swan was nominated for five
Academy Awards and is certified fresh
with a Tomato Meter score of 85 percent
critics say bracingly intense passionate
and wildly melodramatic Black Swan
Glides on Darren arnofsky's bold
Direction and a bravara performance from
Natalie Portman this is supposed to be
my fight this is my shot in the title I
won't get another one after this am I
being selfish am I saying Mickey
Mickey's not if I am I'm sorry I thought
I was fighting for the championship and
I thought you were my mother too
I am your mother
everyone's favorite Boston celebrity no
not Ben Affleck the one in The Departed
no not Matt Damon behold that thought
it's Wahlberg people Mark Wahlberg stars
in The Fighter a biographical Sports
drama directed by David O Russell
Wahlberg is Mickey Ward a professional
boxer with a shot at the world title he
just needs his crack addiction brother
and overpowering manager to be in his
corner and not in his way you're not my
manager anymore and I'm not waiting for
Dicky okay I'm not getting any younger
who's going to look after you sweetheart
I mean come on I know you don't
understand it but I had nine kids and I
love every one of you the same you got a
funny way of showing it letting him get
beat up letting him get his hand broken
the film boasts Dynamic performances by
Wahlberg Amy Adams Christian Bale and
Melissa Leo and was nominated for seven
Oscars winning for best supporting actor
Bale and best supporting actress Leo
with an audience score of 89 this film
really knocked it out of the pack it's
wicked good critics say led by a trio of
captivating performances from Mark
Wahlberg Christian Bale and Amy Adams
the fighter is a solidly entertaining
albeit predictable entry into the boxing
drama genre I heard the raffle and I
felt the ball you missed your shot
Cogburn this is my shot you were more
handicapped without the eyes and I
without the arm I can eat in that side
now in the yard
all right back to Damon True Grit is an
American Western drama brought to you by
the notorious Coen brothers and based on
Charles portis's 1968 novel of the same
name when Outlaw Tom Cheney murders the
father of a young farm girl named Maddie
she enlists the help of a boozy and
trigger-happy Lawman to seek Vengeance
the film stars Jeff Bridges Matt Damon
Josh Brolin and Haley Steinfeld whose
performance made her one of the youngest
Oscar nominees ever they tell me you're
a man with
True Grit
what do you want girl speak up for
supper time let me do that
your makings are too dry
I'm looking for the man who shot and
killed my father Frank Ross in front of
the Monarch boarding house man's name is
Tom Chaney they say he's over in Indian
Territory and I need somebody to go
after him
what's your name girl
my name is Maddie Ross in total True
Grit was nominated for 10 Academy Awards
including best picture best director and
best cinematography and garnered a
certified fresh score of 95 on the
Tomato Meter True Grit more like true
hit critics say girded by strong
performances from Jeff Bridges Matt
Damon and newcomer Haley Steinfeld and
lifted by some of the Cohen's most
finely tuned unaffected work True Grit
is a worthy companion to the Charles
Portis book there you have it our
highlights from a blockbuster heavy year
filled with birds and Dragons Kings and
wizards Cowboys and climbers talking
toys and zombies oh and some dudes from
Boston